the protagonist of the film is a
struggling freelancer Yuki while in a
desperate search for a job one day he is
approached by an old friend Anna she
tells him about an amazing opportunity
to earn a million dollars in a week
although the announcement looks sketchy
they decide to go through with the
admission process just to see where it
leads a few days later both Yuki and
Anna are in a car with a bunch of other
contestants who also applied for the job
they are taken to a bunker-like building
in the middle of nowhere they walk
inside hoping to find an explanation but
the building turns out to be completely
empty a robotic voice then reveals that
they will be living together for the
next week under heavy camera
surveillance with no phones or computers
all they have to do is survive for the
week and take home the one million
dollar prize money at the end this movie
is based on a true Mr Beast video none
of the contestants understand the task
completely but they agree to take part
in it nonetheless a final announcement
gives them one last chance to walk away
but no one does instead they walk
further inside a dining hall and the
door closes behind them initiating day
one on a wall nearby is a timer that
shows how long the participants will
have to stay in the house beneath that
is another set of numbers that no one
understands the meaning of they assume
it is unimportant and decide to focus on
the food on the table the participants
don't fail to notice 10 dolls placed on
the table representing 10 of them a man
named Osaka suggests they introduce
themselves to get to know each other
better it turns out that he is a doctor
who has also brought his wife wakana so
the two can win double the amount of
money I'd say it's more likely that that
doctor's wife is going to kill him next
is a college student named Mackie also
here for the cash Fuji is the oldest
woman in the lot and Ando is a
mysterious alcoholic who doesn't like to
talk a lot everyone introduces
themselves except for a beautiful girl
named Misa and a young man ey in the end
Hiro introduces himself he is the
talkative one who keeps the conversation
going their conversation is then
interrupted by a robotic noise coming
from one of the Dolls the participants
are introduced to the robot attached to
to the ceiling responsible for punishing
the ones who don't follow the rules the
set of rules says that everyone will be
given a room according to a number
assigned to them but no one is allowed
to come out of their rooms after 10 pm
if someone breaks the rules and the
robot finds them they will be eliminated
the group questions what elimination
means but they get no answer according
to the second rule if someone commits a
crime everyone in the house should work
together to solve it one detective will
point fingers at who they think the
criminal is then everyone will vote
their verdict on the matter and
eliminate the alleged criminal the
detective who solves the case will get a
bonus if they survive till the end
lastly the game will end at the end of
the week or when only two survivors are
left the group grows nervous upon
hearing the last rule but Yuki calms
them he claims that if they live
peacefully no one will be harmed and
they will all get the prize money a
while later the old woman in Misa are
cleaning up the dishes when a talkative
hero comes to them with a conspiracy
theory he claims that he recognizes the
old woman from TV and asks her if she is
a serial killer the the old woman
nervously laughs but the comment is
enough to make Misa suspicious somewhere
else we find out that osako lied about
being a doctor to make people trust him
he and his wife wakana are talking about
their genius plan when they are
interrupted by Hero approaching them
with another conspiracy claiming that ey
is a serial killer hero could be a
little more creative with these theories
but it is clear that he is trying to
stir up drama by making people
suspicious of each other but his actual
motive is still unknown in the second
hallway Ando finds blood stains on the
wall he assumes the game they are
playing has been played before by
another group when the clock strikes 10.
everyone goes into their room to avoid
being caught by the robot Yuki finds a
chest by his bed and opens it out of
curiosity inside is a fire poker and a
note that asks him to kill a person with
it Yuki quickly closes the chest and
goes to sleep scared the next morning he
is woken up by Anna who reveals that
every room has a chest with the same
message but a different weapon some
contestants may decide to use their
weapons which means everyone must be
careful suddenly a scream from the
hallway startles everyone it turns out
that someone used their gun and killed
Hiro with five bullets to his body
everyone is shocked except ey who laughs
to himself making the group believe he
is the culprit a scared Yuki tries
running away but the only door to the
outside world is tightly shot the group
now has to investigate who the Killer is
knowing that it is one of them suddenly
the guard carries Hero's dead body to a
room filled with eight coffins for the
eight people who were about to be
eliminated hero is thrown into one of
the coffins before the robot asks
everyone to start the investigation if
the criminal is found the detective the
criminal and the family of the dead body
will be given double the amount of prize
money osako accuses UI of killing Hiro
because he thought he was a serial
killer moreover the fact that he laughed
when he saw the dead body only adds to
the group's suspicion Yuki takes ey's
side and tells everyone to show their
weapons before they start pointing
fingers the one who has a gun will
automatically be the culprit the plan
sounds good but the rest of the group
refuses to oblige because showing their
web would put them in danger since the
killer would go for a member with the
least dangerous weapon eventually ey
gets the majority vote and is declared a
criminal the guard robot picks him up
and throws him in jail in the coffin
room Upon returning to his room Yuki
opens his chest again and is shocked to
see a gun inside the killer has
exchanged his weapon with the fire poker
to blame the murder on Yuki he hides it
scared of being falsely accused then the
group decides to check ewi's weapon out
of curiosity and find it empty they
assume that this means the Killer is
still one of them a while later Yuki
meets Anna in the kitchen and tells her
about the gun insisting that he is Being
Framed by the real killer Anna believes
that he is a good person and trusts his
words on his way to the room Yuki finds
the old woman in Anna's room going
through her stuff she thinks that Anna
is the killer but is proven wrong when
she finds no gun in her chest at night
Yuki checks the gun again and finds out
it isn't missing any bullet confused he
counts them repeatedly and declares that
Hiro was not killed with this gun at the
same time something takes over the old
woman and she decides guides to play
detective going around the house looking
for the killer she is only a few steps
away from the room when a nail hits her
forehead ending her life the camera
moves and we see the Keller is none
other than Misa the next day when the
dead body is found all blame falls on
Anna since everyone knew the old woman
suspected her of being the murderer they
think it was a Revenge murder even
though Anna insists she is innocent Yuki
also takes her side making a Saco
believe he is in on the plan he brings
out a knife telling everyone to back off
and let the culprit be punished Ando
tries calming the situation but is in
turn accused of being the murderer when
pushed he reveals that six months ago
his son left home saying that he had
found a gig that pays a lot of money he
never returned home which is why Ando
decided to investigate this gig himself
he thinks that his son and the people
with him died because they went against
each other the rest of the group
understands his concerns and the
conflict dies down on its own when
everyone goes to sleep Ando comes to
Yuki's room and reveals that he has
found a way to prevent any more deaths
he has figured that the robot moves only
in a clockwise Direction and remains
dormant for 10 minutes before every
round this means if they walk behind the
robot at all times they will be able to
roam around the house without the fear
of being caught this way the group
decides to keep watch in a pair of two
every night to be safe Anna and Yuki
take the first shift and while they are
at it Anna confesses she has started to
like Yuki busy confessing their love
they do not notice the robot turn in a
counterclockwise Direction the robot is
seconds away from catching them before
they hide a few hours in it is wakana
and misa's turn to keep guard however
wakana is late so Yuki decides to stay
with Misa to help her in the room with
the coffins wakana and osako are having
fun together wakana remembers she's
supposed to partner up with Misa and
runs outside to help when osako is alone
the ceiling starts moving and crushes
him to the floor the following morning
everyone finds out about his death it
devastated wakana vows to kill the
person who killed her husband I will get
revenge on on the ceiling suddenly the
ceiling moves again making the group run
out of the room outside they see the
college student holding a remote that
controls the ceiling he says that he
found the remote on the floor and was
just testing it but he knows that no one
else in the room believes him in a
moment of panic he brings out his
crossbow and threatens to kill anyone
who blames him everyone takes a step
back except wakana determined to avenge
her husband's death she hits the guy
with a battle ax later committing the
unthinkable herself with the death of
three people in a row only four
survivors are left it is then revealed
that the strange set of numbers on the
wall is the number of streamers watching
them Yuki is furious that there are
millions of viewers watching them die
for entertainment but he can do nothing
about it later in the evening miza and
Anna are making tea for everyone when no
one is looking Misa puts a drug into the
kettle and serves it to the rest of the
group she discloses that she has a son
back home who is sick and she is here to
collect money for his treatment it is
the very reason she killed the old woman
and is willing to kill everyone else for
the money at night Yuki goes to Miz's
room to talk but suddenly his hands
stopped moving and he falls to the
ground Misa tells him that she has
drugged him and the rest of the group
using a muscle relaxant you won't die
she says but you'll probably poop
yourself she gets ready to kill Yuki but
he manages to push her away and run for
his life in the hallways the robot finds
them and warns them to go back into
their rooms immediately just before it
shoots Yuki runs into a nearby room but
Misa is killed in the commotion the next
morning the effects of the drug wear off
and the three remaining survivors come
out of their rooms they notice that
mise's death scene looks very similar to
how Hiro died this makes Yuki realize
that the first death was a ploy just to
start drama among the participants Hiro
is a spy kept among the participants to
plot them against each other he
volunteered to die so his share of the
money could go to his family from the
very beginning no one would have died if
the group decided to work together and
not against each other the robot
announces that Yuki has gained twice the
prize amount for solving Hiro's case
Yuki brings out his gun and places it on
the table followed by andao doing the
same with his screwdriver they do this
to show complete trust in each other and
also because Ando didn't have a chance
with that screwdriver anyway however
Anna refuses to participate on the
morning of day six Yuki finds xando with
his gun the man puts it away immediately
hence nobody thinks much of it then
comes the final day of the game Yuki
walks out of his room in a good mood
only to find the weapons missing he runs
to andoz and Anna's room but finds no
one while looking for them he notices
the door to the prison is wide open
which means ey has escaped and is
seeking Revenge he also finds ando's
dead body in the coffin and loses his
mind ey takes this opportunity to hold
Yuki in a choke hold it turns out that
the ceiling moving remote was his weapon
and he was the one who killed osako for
putting him in jail the blame came down
to the college kid later on because he
found the remote that ey had thrown
outside shockingly enough ey doesn't
have the gun and claims that he didn't
kill Ando either with only four minutes
left for the game to end Yuki and ey
fight for the screwdriver ey
and is about to kill Yuki before Anna
comes to his Aid with the gun she is
about to shoot but Yuki stops her
remembering that Ando made some changes
to the gun in the morning amidst the
struggle the gun ends up in ey's hands
he fires and dies in the explosion that
follows finally Yuki and Anna are
declared the survivors the door opens
and demand hands Yuki his share of the
prize money even though Anna is left
without any money she doesn't seem that
mad about it she finally reveals that
she is a part of the game like Hiro was
her job was also to pit the participants
against each other and she was the one
who put the gun in Yuki's chest the
person who let ey out of the cage was
also her but when it came down to Yuki's
life she couldn't let him die after
dropping these truths on Yuki Anna
simply drives away in the final scene we
see Ando coming out of the building he
discloses that he pretended to die so no
one would try to kill him on the final
day on their way back to the city Yuki
tosses the bag of money not wanting to
associate with any part of the sick game
the top comment of this video is going
to be about Among Us or squid game just
calling that right now subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching